hi folks Sal here from Khan Academy many
of you all have caught wind that the
national assessment of Education
progress just came out also also known
as the nape or the nation's report card
and the results were not good they were
already bad pre-pandemic and they just
got worse the results were bad both in
English and language arts and in math
but they were worse in math and of the
two cohorts that they measured fourth
and eighth graders they were even worse
in the 8th graders in math and this is
in line with what we've always said math
is fundamentally cumulative in a
traditional system a student gets a a
sixty percent of seventy percent of a
concept they get a c or a d on that exam
the class moves on to the next concept
somehow expecting the student to master
that concept where they weren't
proficient in the previous one and then
all of a sudden the student gets to
eighth grade where we knew they weren't
proficient in almost every unit up to
that point and then we're surprised that
only one-third of students are
proficient in math at that point and
frankly if you measured in 10th Grade or
12th grade those numbers are are just
going to get worse and worse and worse
the other problem is it's not like this
was a uniform if you go to where my kids
go to school you probably have close to
100 percent of students are proficient
but on the other hand if you go to
Detroit if you look at the data
pre-pandemic six percent of students
were proficient post pandemic three
percent of students are proficient
and you can imagine there's a lot of
finger pointing going on people saying
oh it's because of this policy or that
policy but that's not helpful for anyone
the The Helpful thing is to actually
offer Solutions and just last month we
released a very rigorous peer review
study this and we've had over 50 studies
on Khan academies the most studied
platform out there that showed if
students during the pandemic put in just
30 to 60 Minutes a week in Khan Academy
that over the course of the school year
those students not only didn't they
didn't see the declines that I just
described they accelerated by almost 40
percent versus
pre-pandemic National norms
so we have a lot of work we're always
going to be coming being working on
becoming more efficacious more engaging
but the name of the game now is how do
we just get this word out in front of
more students more teachers more parents
and it it's important to have Partners
like yourself who are helping spread the
word who have helped partner and support
with us because I see the next five
years as a moment where we're either
going to serve all of these students
especially students in communities like
Detroit or we're just going to accept
that it's okay that large chunks
two-thirds of three-fourths of American
students really aren't at a level where
they can engage and reach their
potential so I want to thank you all for
being on this journey with us but I
think this journey is about to hit
another gear we have a five-year goal
where we want to accelerate 5 million
American kids especially with an
emphasis on kids from historically
under-resourced communities by 50 or
more and we think we can do that because
one the efficacy studies say that we can
do that but even more important the
nation needs us we're a small
organization the budget of a large high
school and we have a means of moving the
dial for the country but we're going to
need your continued support and your in
continued partnership as we go into this
next phase of of this adventure where
you know frankly if if we're not able to
do it I think in five years we're going
to be seeing the doing the same finger
pointing and having the same narrative
that that everyone has right now so
thank you for being on this journey I
think we're going to be able to solve
this but we're going to continue to need
your help so so thank you for being part
of this